I mean it's just a boob just feed my
baby it's already calm BAM Jesse James
Decker fires back at breastfeeding
backlash the proud mama of to post
photos feeding her young son on
Instagram and told ET she doesn't quite
get the criticism some celebs can go on
the red carpet and they're like nipples
are all out it's cool but if I want to
feed my kid I just think people like to
complain about stuff truly yeah we just
all got to just look at the positive I'm
just feeding the baby it's all good calm
down the 28 year old gave birth to her
baby boy last September but hasn't
rushed back to the gym she explained she
has other priorities was there pressure
for you to put you know your body back
into you know the gym and the diet grind
I just didn't put that pressure on
myself I've said this in the past before
I'd rather focus on raising my new
infants and spending time with my baby
and thinking about my body I think it's
a little selfish and there's one more
thing Jesse isn't doing snapping nude
selfies like this one from Kim
Kardashian can we ever expect something
like that from you what were your
reactions what were your thoughts on
that probably not gonna see me posting
naked pictures of myself I'm all about
you know female empowerment and looking
good and stuff but I just don't think
everyone needs to see all my business I
think that's for Eric to see you know I
probably wouldn't want vide seeing all
that of me but you know if she feels
comfortable more power to her I guess
you